PornHub traffic climbed during the
Hawaii missile alert
of course
like if I'm going out I'm Jay Owen
I'm going out I'm going out balls
emptied all right
[Music]
we'll tagged you pick us your last time
to go out I'm trying to find some funny
stories yeah that's such a good question
holy [__] I mean I have an owl right I
can
I mean I could go through everything at
that time
I'm like you know there'd be a part of
me that's like I wonder if I can do it
to some gay porn you know like I've
never tried so you know maybe now's the
time to like broaden my hair yeah it's
time to broaden my horizons that's just
every time I'm gonna give it a go yeah
this is like like because the reason I
fell into this Rabbit Hole was reading
other people's story because there's so
many like nuances and just little things
I never thought about until I read about
people's experience about it because
like yeah if I did have 30 minutes left
how the [__] would my mind go if I if I
decided to jack off would I would I try
something new or would I put on [__]
Masterpiece one last time for like a
victory lapia
it's up to you man it's one of your
brain decides
where the [__] does your mind go during
that time
I don't even know what I do I I'd
probably be too shocked to think of
anything meaningful in one hour you know
one hour not a lot of time no you'd
probably just go back to top of the
trash right I mean we've already talked
for an hour you can't even you can't
even finish a [__] trash teeth
episode
you're like oh I have one hour to live I
can't wait to watch my favorite trash
[Music]
mum I can watch one YouTube video before
bed a YouTube video
oh my god oh but yeah I mean it's it's
it's interesting just
or we have these interesting case yeah
exactly it's the one hour marker just in
case so right the one at all it's I
think we were about to like reach the
one hour mark so yeah hopefully you put
on this episode if uh missile will cry
if if you're getting like an alert or
something like that a false missile a
false
I wonder if it would ever come back to
bite if it ever did happen again in
Hawaii there's a missile look but it was
actually legit if people didn't believe
it
it was
like unfortunately it's like nice try
government yeah unfortunately being on
an island is probably one of the worst
places you could be during a missile War
because yeah like yeah well um well it's
not even like if you had an hour anyway
even if you're on Mainland and it was
coming for you if there's any meaningful
Direction you could get to an hour yeah
yeah exactly like that's like that's
like two blocks in New York City you
know what I mean yeah you can barely get
out of New York
you can barely get out without a uh
crisis happening and let's say and let's
say even if you were in a metropolitan
area or or in a city or whatever if
there was a missile Alert in a city
you're not getting out of the city
because everyone's trying exactly yeah
like everyone's gonna try and leave yeah
so obviously you know we saw that with
kovid everyone try to leave and certain
cities are being locked down yeah yeah
it was just like we see that even some
things like this that the infrastructure
just crumbles when this many people want
to use it yeah yeah it's like I I I
think would I be that guy who panics and
runs or would I just be the guy who
accepts my face probably be I think I'll
be the guy who accepts my yeah you for
sure would yeah yeah I'm like I've lived
a good life guys you would go to the
wine fridge pop one open and just and
just look outside the window dude and
you were just you were just and to be
fair I join you all right yeah like
probably go on my rooftop or something
like that I didn't know it yeah and and
just like swarmed like my last glass of
wine or something like that and just be
like [__] yeah why not it's a beautiful
day not one good bottle you've been
saving for that occasion yeah especially
if you're in [__] Hawaii imagine how
Zen people must have felt oh in the
climate you know it feels I can't
imagine how depressed we would be in
[__] England with like the rain
coming down it'd be like no that's a
fitting end
that's like everyone's just like
conglomerates to the Palm it's just like
the collapse it was a good one bro that
that would happen that would happen
everyone would go to the nearest [__]
Pub and get that last fighting yeah and
ironically wouldn't be a bad way to go
out yeah yeah cracking the corn
let's say that not everyone has one week
it's just you just me so everything is
is available and everything is normal
right
um so like you know you could get on a
plane you could do all this stuff but no
fast travel obviously no fast travel
literally just within the route like
bounds of what you can do now and money
isn't an issue okay ah well first
obviously you ought to visit your yeah I
would I would go to my family first
obviously that would take like a few
days off my schedule boom three days
gone three days gone
three days off my schedule sorry what's
the run you gotta optimize this am I
staying in England all the time
[Music]
maybe I'm jealous maybe I'm sorry I'm
being pedantic but I'm like hey I'm the
one with the I think what I would want
is to go somewhere that's always been
like at the top of my bucket list and
then go with my family and then just be
like I did it I I made it to the place
I've always wanted to go I'm with the
people that I care about I'm in this
beautiful place I've always wanted to go
yeah I'm good you know I do I would like
I would record a bunch of YouTube videos
that would set to be public like one
five ten years yeah that's that's what I
would do actually
I'll be like guys it's uh I would have
been like 32 years old I would have been
like 35 years old now how's it going on
YouTube is it still the very end this
man is a YouTuber is this size still
active I don't know oh my God yeah
genius content as well oh [__] yeah has
to be paid himself dividends for that
yeah
one year and then five years yeah that's
genius you should do that yeah yeah yeah
he uploaded the video that would go
public you know on yeah interesting
certain amount of years have you ever
thought about like kind of documenting
because there's been few there's been
these kind of people who like take
taking a picture like every day of their
life for example yeah yeah plus we do
document our lives so that's kind of
thing
we literally that was a stupid question
we literally have thousands of hours of
us our lives are two documents get the
point where I have no memory of filming
some videos I have no memory of a good
chunk of videos I do not remember
filming them how the process was at all
no and now I completely understand why
these people who've been creating their
entire life are like I have no [__]
memory of making that thing because I
get it like my video my YouTube video is
like six years ago if you told me do I
have any memory of making that no memory
no no memory not at all I've made so
many but even not just like Memories
like
it's it gets harder to remember some
like just normal days of your life you
know even if if you ask me hey what did
you do last Wednesday you'd really have
to like think back to it right I don't
actually know what I did last week yeah
what did you do last Wednesday
I was on a plane yeah I was
still sick dying yeah I was dying
because and that's just like last week
you know you think you'd remember what
you did last week in good detail but
then go back like what did you do what
what did you do two birthdays ago what
was your birthday celebration and then
you go back even further and you just
realize how little of your life you
[__] remember and it's one of the
reasons even though like I don't take
photo I don't take many photos I've
never been a guy who has taken photos
and it's kind of like I kind of realized
how much it's bitten me in the back now
just there is so many like there's
there's been a lot of trips that I've
not kind of let's say documented or
taken a lot of photos off except for
maybe one photo on my phone yeah and
I've just completely I I have nothing
I have nothing that to remind me of that
trip you know I have nothing to remind
me of that memory because I thought
I I had this like I thought before it's
just like if the Trip's good the
memories are weird baby I got the
memories stored up in here baby that's
what makes it special and I'm like [__]
nah that that was a [__] life
should be like allow me to introduce
myself like I'm sure if this the trip is
special enough for the boys I'm never
gonna forget it yeah I don't even
remember half the [__] that happened on
tour
yeah half the days
which I know I think I don't even
remember every venue God if we didn't
[__] film it I wouldn't remember half
the [__] we did on our road trip special
yeah it's just I remember watching that
car the road trip special and being like
Oh yeah we oh yeah
oh yeah I did say that I completely
forgot that we spent an entire day in
like a Germantown racing go-karts and
[__] like that until I saw it in the
special oh my God yeah I had that when I
when I first saw that drop I was like oh
we did go here
I remember that because I remember like
trying to Ram you off the road oh yeah
that's right I I completely forgot about
like the swan boat though
oh yeah yeah right like he's like we
were old enough for like like 20 minutes
at least 20 30 minutes yeah the bread
was good though the bread was good but
it was good yeah not like and I guess
that's why you know I'm I'm kind of glad
that I've gotten more into the habit of
just like taking photos because it's
like even if it might not seem important
now yeah that's [__] you look back five
ten years from now and being like Oh
yeah you know that wasn't important or
anything like that it wasn't an
important event or a special place or
anything but just seeing that is like
yeah that was nice because also
sometimes you get photos of maybe bad
times and you're like [__] hate that
well I mean that those times you know
you could just be like well you know it
happens so yeah you just delete it yeah
because I've I've always like never felt
the need to take photos because I'm like
everyone around me takes photos and they
upload it to Facebook but hey surprise
surprise no one uses Facebook anymore if
you're uh like our age so I'm like well
[__] if other people takes photos and
don't post it can parents on Facebook
now sorry I just remember let me think
of the people who use Facebook
appearance yeah yeah it's not funny how
that happened like yeah Facebook used to
be this like hip cool thing and now it's
the thing that is just showing his age
yeah yeah I think that it's Facebook has
become the platform that your parents
use and you used to keep in touch with
your older generation of parents and
stuff like that I'm glad my parents
aren't on social media
so glad I am so glad really really glad
holy [__] I'm glad I blocked my dad on
social media I thought your dad blocked
you no you blocked no I blocked him yeah
I I I I look back and I'm like yep you
know back then I was I was annoyed that
they didn't understand social media and
now I'm like thank God my parents aren't
on Facebook on on Twitter aren't doing
on posting [__] yeah I don't want to see
them but I guess my kid will be like why
is my dad always been on social media
his whole life
it's like everyone at school knows
everything about why is there a video of
my dad hitting the dab when he's 20. why
does Dad have hair oh